this is dr. ben Carson the presidential
candidate who just bumped Donald Trump
from the top spot in the Republican
primary race he's a celebrated
neurosurgeon with a habit of making
head-turning comments a lot of people
who go into prison go into prison
straight and when they come out they're
gay but Carson's jumped to the top spot
in the race shouldn't come as a surprise
especially in a race that's about giving
the party's most fervent supporters
something to get excited about which is
something Carson like Trump is doing
right in the way Bernie Sanders has
moved the Democrats especially Hillary
Clinton to the left Donald Trump has
forced a Republican primary race more
towards the right after all Trump shot
to the top of the race early on with
comments about immigration saying he'd
deport 11 million undocumented
immigrants something that seems to
resonate with many Republicans across
the country not long after Trump was
asked when the United States could get
rid of Muslims and he replied we're
going to be looking at a lot of
different things ben Carson catching on
have this same I would not advocate that
we put a Muslim in charge of this nation
but more than just ignoring that the
Constitution doesn't have a religion
test for the Oval Office ben Carson has
continued to take some controversial
positions for instance he said that gun
control measures in Nazi Germany allowed
Hitler to achieve many of his goals he
said abortion even in cases of rape and
incest should be illegal Carson's even
compared women who get abortions to
slave owners and had this to say about
Obamacare Obamacare is really I think
the worst thing that has happened in
this nation since slavery comments like
these have made some people think
Carson's politics are a bit clownish but
it's actually strategy Carson's got a
good campaign team that knows it has
about 90 days to get their candidate in
the headlines the bottom line is both
Trump and Carson have pushed the
Republican primary race more towards the
right
leaving behind candidates everyone
thought would be the top contenders but
while these antics can work for
Republicans and Democrats in the
primaries how far can they get them in
the general election